اليك اسماعيل انت في المستشفى المعمداني
وسط غزه طبعا المنطقه الوسطى تشهد غارات
مكثفه وهذا ما يرفع
عداد الشهداء والجرحى كذلك ضعنا في صوره
اخر
التطورات نعم كانت ليلى عليف على شمال
قطاع غزه بالتحديد في منطقه الصبره ومنطقه
حي الزيتون حي التفاح والدرج ومنطقه شرق
حي الزيتون هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى
منطقه مخيم الشاطق هذه المناطق التي تعرضت
لاحزن ناريه عنيفه دمر الاحتلال عددا من
البنايات السكنيه استطعنا ان نصل الى بعض
الاصابات والشهداء الذين وصلوا الى مستشفى
المعمداني لكن هناك الكثير من الجثامين
بقيت اسفل الانقاذ قوات الاحتلال صباء فجر
هذا اليوم دمرت منزلين لعائله مدوخ والعما
وي في منطقه الصبره بالاضافه الى تدمير
منزلين اخرين في منطقه الثلاثين هذين
المنزلين يتبعان لعائله شحيبر والقصاص
وصلل العديد من الاصا اصبات الى داخل
مستشفى المعمداني وبقيت الشهداء اسفل
الانقاظ تحاول الطواقم رغم المعدات
المتهالكه انتشال هؤلاء الجثامين على
الرغم من انه لا يتوفر اي بواق وعلى الرغم
انه لا يتوفر اي حتى جرافات ولا يتوفر
وقود لتشغيلها حتى ان توفرت بالاضافه لذلك
قصف قوات الاحتلال محيط برج داوود مما ادى
الى ذلك الى سقوط العديد من الاصابات في
منطقه الرمال حيث يتواجد هذا البرج
الكثافه السكانيه كانت مرتفعه لكن شهدت
هذه المنطقه نزوحا كبيرا من المناطق
الغربيه الى المناطق الشرقيه والى المناطق
المختلفه القصف العنيف والفرار من هذا
القصف تسبب بحاله نزوح شديده جدا وكبيره
جدا الى المناطق الشرقيه المدمره علما ان
منطقه الشجاعيه التي نزح اليها الاهالي او
حتى منطقه التفاح والدرج هذه المناطق هي
مدمره بفعل قوات الاحتلال وبفعل الاحتلال
البري والعمليه العسكريه التي استمرت
لايام طويله لكن التطور و فقدان طواقم
الهلال الاحمر الاتصال مع طواقمها التي
ذهبت لانتشال الطفله التي بقيت لساعات
طويله الى اسفل القصف الاسرائيلي قرب
طرمبه فارس هذه الطفله التي هي من عائله
حماده هي ناجيه وحيده من قصف اسرائيلي
لسياره مدنيه وهي هاربه من القصف
الاسرائيلي قرب طرمبه فارس في محيط تل
الهواء هذه احد افراد العائله يحدثنا اكثر
عن ما حصل في الساعات الاخيره لو تحدثنا
يا عم عن الاسم التفاصيل لهذه الطفله
بالامس كان اخويا بشار امبارح الله يرحمه
حارب هو واسرته جميعا في سيارته وتم قصفه
واستهدافه بعد ساعتين تم التواصل من قبل
طفلتين كانوا معه ابنائه في السياره
الطفله الاولى رغد استشهدت بعد العصر وهي
بتناشد من شان الله الحقوني انا مصابه
وانا بنزف تم بقي طفله صغيره لا يتجاوز
عمرها ست سنوات تم التواصل معها لحد بعد
المغرب وكان في مناشده من قبل الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني وتم التوجه من قبل
الاسعاف الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ولحد هذه
اللحظه لم يتم الاتصال او التواصل مع
الاسعاف ولا نعرف عن شيء عن هذه الطفله
لذلك نناشد الصليب الاحمر نناشد جميع
المؤسسات الدوليه نناشد جميع احرار العالم
بالتدخل لانقاذ هذه الطفله التي بقيت هي
الوحيده من اهلها ظل الاتصال مع ما فيش اي
اتصال منذ امس الساعه خسه وحتى هذه اللحظه
واحنا قاعدين في المستشفى بناشد جميع
احرار العالم لانقاذ هذه الطفله الطفله
اسم الطفله هند حماده نعم هذه الطفله هند
الذي بقيت وحدها وهي ابنه الست سنوات في
هذه السياره العائله لازالت تناشد مؤسسات
الدوليه ومؤسسات حمايه الطفل لانتشال هذه
الطفله التي بقيت تحت القصف الاسرائيلي
لساعات طويله وحتى هذه اللحظه وفق ما
اعلنت جمعيه الهلال الاحمر انها فقدت
الاتصال مع الطواقم التي توجهت الى ذاك
المكان بتنسيق اسرائيلي مباشر حتى هذه
اللحظه الطواقم الطبيه ولساعات الليل
الطويل نحن انتظرنا في داخل مستشفى
المعمداني لتصل هذه الطواقم لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تصل وبالاضافه ان وحدات الهلال
الاحمر اعلنت فقدانها مع الطاقم الذي توجه
لانتشال هذه
الطفله شكرا جزيلا لك اسماعيل الغول
مراسلنا من المستشفى المع مداني